faire une passe décisive à son futur
employeur dribbler un potentiel
collaborateurs c'est la dernière
innovation de l' agence départementale
activity avec ce match de football entre
recruteurs et demandeurs d'emploi
un événement organisé le 11 février
dernier à guyancourt
pour certaines personnes n'a finalement
on est plus en confiance quand on est
sur un terrain de foot que quand on est
enfermé entre quatre murs dans un bureau
à devoir se présenter d'une façon hyper
formelle prise d'initiative
communication et travaille en équipe le
savoir être des personnes suivies par
activity s'exprime sous l'attention des
dix représentants d'entreprises et
footballeurs pour une soirée on a
rarement l'occasion finalement de
rencontrer plusieurs profils en une
seule fois et bon bah là ça a commencé
par un jeune qui vient de se présenter à
nous qui rencontrait les dirigeants de
colas donc très sympas ils sont j'ai pu
j'ai pu leur échange et de trois mois
avec eux j'ai essayé de me présenter au
mieux
donc on a moins d'insérer leur groupe
est bien sûr donc aulas et l'entreprise
c'est assez structuré qu'on connaît qui
tiennent debout depuis longtemps ici au
siège de l'entreprise bd comme à
elancourt signer traoré 26 ans suit une
formation d'habilitation électrique
cet habitant de la verrière a rejoint
cette pme spécialisée dans l'ingénierie
électrique grâce à activity après une
période d'essai il a été embauché en cdi
dans la boîte ici on fait vraiment du
courant fort courant faible le coffre
d'accès a vraiment peu diversifiée des
combes auront beaucoup de choses donc
j'ai appris en cours en fonction
c'est en travaillant et présenté en
s'impliquant travail rigoureux ponctuel
motivé
d'abord monteur il est aujourd'hui
techniciens et transmet déjà son savoir
faire à des apprentis et des stagiaires
la jeunesse une priorité pour cette
société
on a une vraie volonté en fait
d'intégrer des jeunes pour leur offrir
de l'emploi
c'est la politique de bd comme de ces la
jeunesse et surtout offrir une chance à
des jeunes créés en 2015 activité est un
groupement d'intérêt public créé par le
conseil départemental et la préfecture
sept agences accompagnent les
bénéficiaires du rsa les jeunes entre 18
et 25 ans les demandeurs d'emploi de
longue durée et les publics des
quartiers politique de la ville
cela à travers un réseau d'entreprises
et d'acteurs
l'emploi et de l'insertion notre mission
première aussi c'est la remise en
activité pour le retour à un plan mais
c'est vraiment de permettre aux
personnes publiques d'avoir accès à une
activité qui va les remettre dans une
dynamique pour le retour à l'emploi
on ne pouvait pas se permettre de
regarder monter ses bénéficiaires du rsa
monte le nombre avec des vrais poches de
pauvreté qu'on voyait apparaître sur les
territoires on les a accompagnés
justement avec la création de cette
agence activity qui est une autre façon
de voir l'accompagnement social
puisqu'on est aussi dans
l'accompagnement de la
professionnalisation
une nouvelle manière d'accompagner
l'insertion professionnelle notamment à
travers le sport d'autres matchs de
football devrait être organisé des
olympiades de l'emploi pourrait même
voir le jour fin 2019